muley hatched two tiny turtles make
their first-ever journeys to the sea
it's a precious moment these hawksbills
are critically endangered but this year
an unprecedented six nets have been made
on this beach that's the first time that
we have so many nests as you can see
right now but at least triple the amount
of nest from previous experiences I
think it's a good sign that nature has
some time to recover in this special
circumstances and special times you know
so I think for us it's wonderful to see
that nature is a back little bit animals
are reclaiming areas cleared of tourists
by KO bid 19 on the neighboring bay
hundreds of green turtles have hatched
Thailand's wildlife seemingly reveling
in the temporary while coronavirus has
forced humanity into lock downs and
confinement the pandemic has given
nature the time and space to thrive the
once constant harm of tourist boats has
gone from Koh Samui locals say the water
is already cleaner and teeming with fish
across the country often hidden animals
are now frequently spotted since
coronavirus closed national parks to
visitors in March the government says
the environmental impacts been so
profound it's ordered they now shut for
at least two months every year and limit
tourist numbers we could call it bump it
I'm doing yet no hint appear so much hot
food no such bad little tea if we would
have kin-por hon a llama green man can't
eat octopus ya neck until 10 p.m. and
midnight have been bent and he took
tongue pop but not to be rely enough but
the break from humans is temporary and
the threats many species face a vast
can I be alive let us because usually
their total s is like a circle right
like a bowl but this shape is change is
maybe a fungal only nine eggs in this
nest have successfully hatched but with
the final survivors hope tiny new lives
a fresh chance for these endangered
creatures Shiva Robin's Sky News Koh
Samui Thailand